hello everyone and welcome to Game three
of the finals of the 1971 candidates
cycle again it's Bobby Fisher versus
Tigran Petrosian
and it's it's been said that after
losing Game two Fischer ran all the way
from the San Martin theater in Buenos
Aires all the way to his hotel room
which is like five blocks away while
being chased by news reporters and while
this may or may not be true a person who
works there currently said that he was
told this by a person who worked in the
San Martin theatre for over 50 years and
that he was present there during this
match so okay well it my may or may not
be true it's it's an interesting story
so why not share it and you've seen game
one really a beautiful game played by
Petros on which Fischer in India and one
patron wasn't able to reach time control
in Game two would the white pieces
Petrosyan played simply a brilliancy and
crushed fishery and thirtysomething
moves and now we are about to see game 3
which in my opinion is even more
interesting than game 1 and game 2 and
you can definitely sense that Tigran
Petrosian is a much different opponent
then then those who favor faced so far
so without further ado Fischer opens the
game of course with white pieces he
plays efore East six we have the French
defense on the board d4 d5 and Knight to
c3
we have Knight to f6 the classical
variation of the French butter up to g5
and now D captures on e4 Knight captures
on e4 Bishop to e7 and now Bishop
captures on f6 and here G captures on f6
is played are creating imbalances in the
position you can see that pitocin is
definitely up for a fight
Bishop captures is also possible but
then after all of the pieces are
exchanged let's say Knight of three
white it didn't really achieve anything
out of the opening but it's it's highly
unlikely that anyone can push for
something in this position
I mean it's of course playable by both
sides but you know if you're already
playing black and you decide to go for
this variation then gene captures on f6
you know creating a stronger center you
get a semi-open file for your rook very
very nice
nice position for black so ok g3 as
pitocin does have the semi open file it
makes sense to play g3 as per Fischer is
planning the Castle kingside I will have
f5 Knight to c3 and now Bishop to f6
placing the position to a much active
square Knight G to E - defending the d4
pawn and now Knight to c6
with a triple attack against the d4 pawn
here Fischer pushes d5 and ok we have a
captures on d5 you might ask ourselves
why capture here why not wait for white
to capture and then I will under boo my
pawns well it is possible but let's say
97 now you capture on e6 Queen captures
rook captures and for example now F
captures on e6 yes you won doubled your
pawns but then you have to face Knight
b5 it's not all that clear how to
prevent this Knight captures on c7 let's
say Bishop to e5 and now f4 doesn't
really do all that much simply a6 let's
say Knight 84 and after c6 attacking the
knight and now you will get F 4 and
after Bishop to be a 290x tonight goes
back to c3 and yes you have unabled your
pawns but now you have a weak a 6 pawn
and also your pieces are completely
undeveloped not something you you want
to go for with the black pieces so ok d5
we have it captures on d5 and then out
comes Knight captures on d5 Bishop to
capture some b2
we have Bishop - G - now this is an
excellent move by Fischer he tries to
offer an exchange here but it would be
very risky to actually grab the rope
here for example if Petrosyan captures
the rook then Queen captures and now of
course this comes with an attack against
the HH rook let's say castles nice to
have 6 check King moves and now you can
see that while Fischer does have all of
these discoveries they are not yet all
that useful so let's a bunch of
characters V captures now Fischer
castles and still there's no way to
break this terrible threat of the night
moving and delivering this this check so
doesn't really matter whatever you
realize said bushel to a6 you attack
here
rook to d1 simply attacking the Queen
once the Queen moves you get this rook
to D sell
move and now you can see that the Queen
has to move or you can give up your
queen and then lose the game that way
but to let's say Queen captures on e2
now you have this beautiful night to e
ee8 check if you move the king then of
course Queen captures on g7 will be
checkmate you have to block with f6 and
now comes knife captures on f6 and now
it doesn't matter you will either
capture tonight and this will be met
with Queen captures on f6 would check
King g8 Queen g7 checkmate or on the
other hand which is an even greater idea
if you try Queen to f1 check to give up
the Queen this way and you know get the
Queen off of a 1 then Queen captures
Bishop captures and of course comes rope
captures on h7 which will again be
checkmate so definitely a very nice
exchange sacrifice and Petrosyan of
course does not go for it here petrosyan
castles we have castles by Fischer again
it's way too dangerous to capture the
rook
Petrosyan moves back the butcher butcher
back to h8 and now comes tonight e to F
for Fischer is making a room for the
screen to enter the attack and it's it's
a very nice position for white but
although it seems like a very passive
position for black it's actually a very
solid position for black as Tigran will
show Knight to e5 a very nice move
preparing either nice the g4 or if
needed nice the g6
it's ok first replace our Queen to h5
and Petrosyan simply moves a Knight to
g6 just so you get the idea of how many
dangers there are in the position let's
say he goes Knight to g4 then you get
this rook a to e1 move and now the
problem with the knight being on g4 is
that it no longer defends the e7 square
so now whatever you play here let's say
Bishop to g7 you get knife to e7 check
King moves and now Knight e to g6 check
the h7 pawn is pinned you have to
capture and now after Knight captures
here ok you have to move the King and
now you don't capture the rook but
rather Bishop to d5 check the King has
no squares only legal moves Queen
captures well not only legal you can
also give up some material but you know
it wouldn't really help you Queen
captures on d5 and now
have nice to e7 check you lose the Queen
and of course you will now lose the game
very very quickly so okay after Queen to
h5 Knight to g6 by petrosyan we have
rook a to d1 na rook a to e1 isn't all
that powerful because the night from g6
is already guarding e7 so okay we have
c6 attacking the knight and now the
knight doesn't really have all that
other great discoveries ok the rock is
dying the Queen but nothing you do is
all that dangerous an interesting move
would be nice to each three and now of
course if you capture the knight - gee
if I will win the game there's really
nothing much black can do here but the
problem is after Knight to h3 you don't
capture but rather you go Bishop to g7
and now Knight g5 you can simply play h6
and now both of your pieces are under
attack now it's actually black that wins
this game so ok after c6 official goes
back night to e3 opens up an attack
against Pedro since Queen we have Queen
to f6 and now King to h1 Fischer wants
to pile up on this doubled f5 pawn for
example Bishop to h3 would create a
triple attack but now Petrosyan can
simply play Knight captures pawn
captures and Queen to g6 check which
seems like it straight away
straights Queens but it's actually a
really funny variation where Queens will
not be traded for example you don't want
to capture here because black will on
double his pawns so white will play
Queen g5 and of course black doesn't
want to capture because white will under
his double points so let's say Bishop to
f6 black tries to force white to capture
on g6 what will simply go back into g3
and now black can try to force an
exchange in g6 once again of course you
cannot capture the Queen is pinned but
now Queen to g2 and now let's say King
h8 preparing the roof to come to the G
file King to h1 and the now rock the g8
and here white can seem to Blakey a
queen to f3 and even though it seems
like the real problem was the trading of
Queens Queens would actually not be
traded because it doesn't suit either
player and after Bishop Lee six black
will develop all of his pieces and he
has a lot of activity this rock will
come to d8 and black will be better here
so after this Queen to f6 move
we said that the bishop - three doesn't
work right immediately so first came to
h1 so after an exchange comes queen g6
will not come with check so okay Bishop
to g7 Bishop to h3 now creating a triple
attack against the f5 pawn Knight c7
defending the f5 pawn and now rook to d3
okay we have Bishop to e6 patrols and
keeps on developing we have looked after
d1 Fischer doubles up on the D file and
now comes Bishop to h6
and here rook to d4 also a very
interesting move would have been Bishop
captures and Knight captures bishop on
e6 F captures and now rook to d7 seems
like a very active square for the rook
but now you get this Knight to d5 move
and now after I say rook captures here
you get Queen to g6 Queen captures H
captures and now of course you don't
want to capture here - undable to fix
black's pawn structure but rather Knight
c4 and then after Bishop to g7 seems
like fish respond structure would be
slightly better but not all that much
both of them would have three pawn
islands and doesn't seem like you will
be able to push for for anything here c6
is a weak pawn but it's very unlikely
that you will be able to take any any
advantage so official goes rook to d4 he
says ok if you capture here I'll simply
recapture I'll have a a quadruple attack
against the DF 5 porn and this will be
fine but petrosyan says not really he
plays Bishop captures we have rook
captures now there's a really no no way
to add extra defensive defense to this
pawn so rook a to d8 and here we have
rook captures rook captures and now
Bishop captures on f5 so Fischer grabbed
that extra F pawn
Petrosyan has doubled and now we have
Knight captures and i-59 captures an f5
we have
rook captures and if a rope to d5 now
pinning this night here and now it's a
very interesting how do you unpin here
for example nice to h6 seems like a very
nice move but it doesn't really do all
that much okay you open up an attack
against Pedro since Queen but your own
queen is still under attack so there's a
real no way to
do anything here let's say King g7 of
the night is attacked twice you don't
have the option of grabbing the rope
first because Bishop captures comes with
check so you will no longer be able to
grab black screen and on the other hand
even if you don't do this if you try
something like root captures on f6 then
you get a rope captures on age 5 and
again two of your pieces are under
attack you would be you would be forced
to give up the exchange here and then
you would have a rope black would have a
rope against a knight easily winning
endgame
so okay after rook to d5 Fischer played
the only move possible Queen g4 again
not doing anything King will move and
now there's really nothing to do your
knight is still pinned as the bishop is
attacking the Queen and a move like
Queen here to try and trade off the
Queen's that will be met with Queen 2 a1
check King moves and number shock
captures again loses a piece so okay
after rook to d5 we have g4 now Fischer
protects the pawn the the piece pretty
much the only move that was possible
here Bishop captures pawn captures and
now comes h6 a move like rook to d2
again not doing all that much seems like
a very active move but then the h7 pawn
will be a target for example rook g4
check King moves and now Queen captures
on h7 so first h6 now ditch a seventh
one will no longer be a target I will
have h3 by Fischer and the now comes
king - king - h7 it was a somewhat of a
theme after this game that rook to d2
would have been better here in this
position that you know you will be able
to grab some material and but it doesn't
seem to be the case for example Queen to
f3 and now if you grab on c2 then you
get a rope to g4 check King to h7 and
now you have this Queen to f4 move this
is the problem and now let's say rook
captures on a 2 this will be met with
Queen to b8 and now the game is drawing
the thread is of course Queen to g8
checkmate so after we prevent this I you
get Queen after some b7 and now whenever
you try to activate the Queen White will
simply respond by creating further made
threats
Queen - a trade simply Queen to d7 now
King goes back to f6 now Queen t8 you
are no longer
go Queen to h8 because of Queen captures
on f7 so you do have to prevent mate
somehow you have to push h5 but now
simply Queen g8 King goes here and now
come to f8 check King h7 Queen checks
King get six Queen goes here King h7
Quinjet checking h6 and it will be a
draw by by threefold repetition so okay
after h3 our King to h7 was played and
the now comes the Queen - e - now
Fischer doesn't allow rope - D - to be
played we have Queen to e5 offering a
queen trade the pressure goes back a
Queen to h5 now simply capturing an f4
will be met with Queen captures here and
of course this will again result in in
the draw by repetition so we have Queen
to f6 by Petrosyan Queen back to e2 and
that now comes rook to e5 attacking
Fischer screen if you play rook captures
on i-5 then you get Queen to d3 simply
attacking the pin piece and now if King
g6 again you get Ruby for check King
moves rock here King moves I will simply
keep attacking the pin piece Ruby's a
king g6 root or up to four check and now
we will have a again a draw by
repetition because if you go to h5 then
you lose the game due to Queen to d1 now
whatever you do you either lose the
Queen you either lose the rook or if you
don't move the Queen or the rook for
example if you play any other move then
you get rook to g5 check a discovered
check from the Queen and also a check
from the rook you have to capture or go
to h4 doesn't really matter Queen to g4
will be checkmate so here after the
screen to e to move Petrosyan played
rock to e5 we have Queen back to d3
now defending the f5 pawn rook the d5
and after Queen to e to the players
agreed to a draw so a very eventful game
and really really a crazy game get this
game 3 I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you are enjoying the Fischer petrosyan
series so far and the entire Fischer
story
it's I mean ok you could argue that
Fischer has double def points so perhaps
black is better here and ok blacks
position is definitely better but two of
them agreed that there's no way to push
for any actual advantage here and of
course they agreed to a draw so I do
hope you enjoyed it
I would like
to think Sheila's an arson Allen Davis
adjustment Olsen senator Dole each
Indian prong in for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
with another interesting video now thank
you all and I'll see you soon